during week three of the 2017 lck summer
split SKT Blanc landed in a sink kick
only sin against Africa free one more
wave and oh whoa okay thanks going on in
he practice / oh and this guy is showing
up finally holy crap yes however it's
not the first time we've seen a godly
Lee sin play with so many over the years
we decided to compile a list of the top
ten recent plays of all time coming in
at number 10 is dar Doc's quadruple
against energy during the 2016 spring
quarter final I think GBM say that all
right I gets one trainer back in by GBM
lissandra's logo and the front line goes
Warlow a triple kill birds are dock
killing everybody with a Quadra kill
head so you've got one more to go so
he's going to go off to the side here
follow konkwon and phoenix is just
controlling this choke point the dive in
from GBM and then all of the Ultimates
across that backline but they only end
up picking up piglet and then the rest
of the fight is just quickly spread they
have good consistent damage there
our ninth spot goes to amazing kicks off
of expec a onto yellow star during the
2014 new LCS spring split it was such a
Christmas now going even further Wow
superb stuff from amazing they're
landing the kick off the back eight
following straight across and also all
yellow so just hunting him back into all
the team grabbing the eighth spot is CLG
Dexter and his ridiculously sin play
against lmq and he even manages to pick
up the kill zero here comes Ackerman
Dilla for v5ls you will it be good
enough Vasily very low the Q lens
releases they don't say that
and the shutdown now Stoney's got
nowhere to go three kill picks up
acraman goes in for this fight but is it
going to be enough he's taking I take a
look at this deck to play because Elance
acute release all right yeah blah blah
blah more doesn't get to use this dodges
tough break for him now till he gets low
he lands the queues detectives like oh
my god I lay to the queue he needs to go
over safeguard to the ward then just a
time to take his second activation and
kick back facili
what they reject our seven goes to
dandies Leeson mechanics while
interrupting Starks recalls
bloodthirster infinity edge and man up
dancer now so much quality though Oh
take the fighter fighter and he can kill
it oh no ya dandy may actually kill her
there goes boy goodbye double kill and
getting it struck baby Sirico canceled
oh he's going to get the triple all or
is it yes he is dark in trouble dandy
with the Leafs in top-tier play here
there it is
we'll give it to of other pistol strips
or why not and the crowd goes wild
coming in six is peanuts perfectly sin
play in SKT base during the 2016 World
Championship semi-final minutes of
Defense
just like the previous game is still
rocking a bit of a tall scale to sell
their Wow
that's the name I speed up these minute
hitters out as well fine before keep on
going peanut is exquisitely gently right
there burning the arcane shift of his
first sonic wave and then killing him on
the second one that was just perfect and
it's exactly what rocks needed to
continue to push in sealing the fifth
spot is diamond double kill during the
2014 you LCS spring split all right I
think dudes get it pick up diamond good
time track around the side parties gets
a sonic wave that takes him down array
hunts ready back in there and now
Freddie's in trouble now he didn't
really read the Blair I think he was
expecting it to work out so well but I'm
a prop through the king of the jungle is
still alive on leasing our fourth spot
goes to liras game breaking play on
envious during the 2017 summer promotion
tournament Stefan Slater and newest omen
for a bit of tanki statistics it has
gone free Quicksilver Sastre himself
gets locked up by something you will be
able to line up to get out goes in uses
fans horn to kick being exact in step
Dorion it down there's no commands
shockwave left open bullet time tries to
go across the members of envy but
they've chunked out mash this chunk out
fans horn and they've taken down the
inhibitor Lyra makes the game breaking
play for team and be they're grabbing
the third spot it's insects iconic Lee
sin played during the 2013 all-star
tournament
very very look at the pull-up in the end
what they're ready through the resident
normal filtering our judge and they're
going to chase our diamond there is an
accidental fall and the start of this
fight was just so key when insect comes
in behind LT Susan board back kicked in
that is so hard to execute even though
Europe tried to come wouldn't mean
really everyone hit on the rumble
ultimate they'd already lost their ad
carry and they burned all their CC
really is a counter vitiation so the
rest of Korea just changed out you
coming in second is b9 Russia's epic
play against CLG during the 2016 na LCS
spring split he pops the heel and
there's the reengage jet was a
mechanical a play and now he's aa but he
treatment package so now it's up to rush
who he's out of mana to keyboard ah holy
crap Georgia's the rock and the fight
continued expect against the shield to
fight it had buzzed away the Sun is so
sneaky with the fighters door shut race
went back there football keeping in oh
my god geez I got fine in the wondrous
one our number one spot goes to dandies
insane five-man Leeson Altman with a
single kick he won the entire team fight
Andy getting this by know I think bangs
in trouble there's the kick they kick it
in all the Dennis Potter nearly comes
into the box and MVP ozone is going to
absolutely slaughter
Synnex last goodbye bang look at that
kiting my bang nice dueling but there's
not enough perfect days an absolutely
flawless set up at be fight so I
probably the best people I have never
seen a five man
so there you have it those were our
picks for the top 10 Lee sin plays of
all time did we miss anything let us
know in the comments below thanks for
watching if you want more great content
be sure to hit that subscribe button
[Music]